- L'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au gouvernement.
La première question va être posée
par monsieur Christophe Naegelen.
- Christophe Naegelen: Je tenais à
souhaiter à tous mes meilleurs
voeux pour cette année 2023, je
les adresse surtout à nos
concitoyens, des voeux de santé,
d'espoir et de courage.
Monsieur le ministre de
l'Economie, j'aurais pu vous
parler de cette usine textile qui
a vu sa facture d'électricité
annuelle passer de 1 million à 2
millions d'euros, et qui se
retrouve encore plus en difficulté
face à la concurrence
internationale.
J'aurais pu aussi vous parler de
ce boulanger de la Bresse qui a vu
sa facture mensuelle passer du
simple au double, l'obligeant à
augmenter sa baguette de 30%.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Est-ce que
vous pouvez vous installer dans le
silence pour que l'on puisse
écouter la première question de
l'année?
- Christophe Naegelen: J'aurais pu
vous parler de ce restaurateur qui
va devoir s'acquitter d'une
facture de 90.000 euros alors
qu'elle était de 9600 euros l'an
passé.
Il hésite à poursuivre son
activité.
Cette situation, loin d'être
unique, impacte tous les Français.
Elle a des conséquences a minima
compliquées et parfois
catastrophiques.
Monsieur le ministre de
l'Economie, nous n'allons pas
débattre à nouveau des causes.
Ce qui intéresse nos concitoyens,
c'est le futur, demain: comment
résoudre ces problèmes au plus
vite?
J'ai une question à l'échelle de
l'Union Européenne.
Lorsque la France était à la
présidence du Conseil européen, le
président avait évoqué une refonte
du marché européen de
l'électricité.
Que comptez-vous faire aujourd'hui
et prévoyez-vous de sortir de ce
marché?
Au niveau national, de nombreuses
entreprises, principalement nos
PME, ne sont pas concernées par
les aides.
Quand elles le sont, elles
rencontrent des difficultés pour y
avoir droit.
Que comptez-vous faire pour aider
ces personnes au bord de la route?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Madame la
présidente, mesdames et messieurs
les députés, j'adresse d'abord mes
meilleurs voeux pour cette
première question à l'ensemble de
la représentation parlementaire.
Puisque vous m'y invitez,
j'aimerais vous présenter les
mesures d'aides que nous avons
mises en place avec la Première
ministre et le président pour
toutes les entreprises françaises
qu'il faut.
Les très petites entreprises sont
aujourd'hui les mieux protégées de
toutes les petites entreprises de
l'Union Européenne.
Il y a 2,1 millions de très
petites entreprises.
1,5 million d'entre elles ont
droit au tarif régulé et sont
protégées par le bouclier
tarifaire.
Aucun autre pays européen n'a mis
de bouclier tarifaire en place
pour les petites entreprises.
Elles ont lancé un cri d'appel à
l'aide.
Nous les avons entendues en leur
garantissant après de longues
négociations un tarif moyen de
l'électricité à 280 euros le
mégawatt heure en moyenne sur
l'année 2023.
C'est une protection massive que
nous leur apportons.
Tous les boulangers de France,
tous les artisans, toutes les très
petites entreprises de moins de 10
salariés, toutes les professions
qui étaient inquiètes peuvent être
rassurées.
Leur facture ne dépassera pas 280
euros en moyenne sur l'année 2023.
Les entreprises qui auraient
encore des difficultés auront
droit à un guichet qui peut
réduire la facture jusqu'à 40%.
Les très petites entreprises
françaises sont protégées comme
aucune autre entreprise dans
l'Union Européenne.
Reste les PME.
Nous allons continuer à y
travailler avec Olivia Grégoire.
Sur le plan de l'énergie, vous
attendrez la question suivante
pour que je vous apporte une
réponse précise.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Laurence
Vichnievsky.
- Laurence Vichnievsky: Merci.
Je pense que ma question s'adresse
à la fois à monsieur le ministre
de l'Economie et à madame Agnès
Pannier-Runacher.
Sur le thème de l'électricité, le
1er février prochain, la hausse
des factures d'électricité des
Français sera encore plus
considérable.
Elle est pourtant contenue par le
bouclier tarifaire mis en place
par le gouvernement.
Les Français ne comprennent pas
cette explosion des prix alors que
nous disposons de ressources
énergétiques stables et pérennes,
largement grâce à nos centrales
nucléaires.
Le système est opaque, et son
fonctionnement, illisible.
Nombre d'artisans et de
commerçants risquent de ne pas
passer l'hiver.
Les alertes quotidiennes de nos
boulangers en témoignent.
Si nous devons accompagner nos
entreprises et les ménages dans
l'immédiat, ce soutien ne peut
être éternel.
Le prix de notre électricité ne
peut plus dépendre de celui du
gaz.
Monsieur le ministre, madame la
ministre, pouvez-vous expliquer
aux Français pourquoi la France ne
peut pas sortir du système
européen qui paraît nous
pénaliser?
Je pense aux dérogations qui ont
été accordées à l'Espagne et au
Portugal.
Nous savons que des discussions
sont engagées avec nos voisins
pour rendre le prix de l'énergie
plus juste et plus conforme aux
ressources de chacun.
Où en sommes-nous?
Quand peut-on espérer aboutir?
Les Français nous attendent sur
notre sujet déterminant pour le
climat social.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Agnès
Pannier-Runacher.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
d'abord, tous mes voeux pour cette
nouvelle année.
Madame la députée Vichnievsky,
merci de rappeler tous les efforts
faits par le gouvernement qui ont
encore été mis en avant à
l'instant par monsieur le ministre
de l'Economie pour protéger les
Français contre l'augmentation du
prix de l'électricité et du prix
du gaz.
Nous sommes le pays qui protège le
plus nos ménages et nos
entreprises contre l'augmentation
de ces tarifs.
Merci de me donner l'occasion de
dire que ce bouclier est en partie
financé par une mesure qui a été
prise au niveau européen, une
mesure qui permet de prendre la
rente que génèrent ces hauts prix
du gaz et de l'électricité, et de
faire en sorte de la redistribuer
aux consommateurs.
C'est le sens de notre action,
c'est de faire en sorte que, de
manière équilibrée, les
consommateurs puissent bénéficier
de cet effet d'augmentation des
prix et que cela leur revienne.
Cela doit permettre de les
protéger aujourd'hui.
Vous m'interrogez aussi sur la
réforme du marché de
l'électricité.
D'abord, sachez que cela fait deux
ans que nous avons entamé des
discussions pour découpler le
marché du gaz du marché de
l'électricité, mais si nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans le marché
européen et si nous passons
l'hiver dans de bonnes conditions,
c'est parce que nous bénéficions
des exportations d'électricité de
l'Espagne et de l'Allemagne
lorsque notre propre système
électrique est en tension.
Si les prix de l'électricité ont
augmenté, ce n'est pas simplement
la faute des prix du gaz.
C'est aussi le fait
qu'aujourd'hui, notre système
électrique est sous tension pour
des raisons de maintenance de nos
centrales nucléaires.
L'action du gouvernement est très
claire, une action déterminée pour
la réforme du marché de
l'électricité en Europe et une
action déterminée pour renforcer
le système électrique.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, madame
la ministre.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Marleix pour le groupe Les
Républicains.
- Olivier Marleix: Madame la
Première ministre, la droite
française a toujours assumé de
réformer les retraites pour
sauvegarder notre système par
répartition.
La répartition, c'est un principe
de solidarité dans lequel c'est le
travail des Français qui financent
les retraites, c'est le contraire
du "chacun pour soi", c'est le
système le plus protecteur pour
les Français les plus modestes.
Aujourd'hui, ce système est
menacé.
Là où il y avait quatre actifs
pour un retraité dans les années
70, il n'y en a plus qu'un.
Les déficits annoncés auront une
seule conséquence: la baisse du
niveau des pensions pour les
retraités, et nous le refusons.
La réforme que nous voulons, elle
tient en quelques principes.
D'abord, elle doit être
progressive et le recul de l'âge
ne doit intervenir qu'au rythme
d'un trimestre par an jusqu'à 63
ans et à la fin de ce quinquennat,
64 ans dans le suivant.
Elle doit être juste et elle doit
permettre à celui qui a commencé
plus tôt de partir à la retraite
plus tôt, dès lors qu'il a tous
ses trimestres.
Elle doit aussi être équitable en
demandant le même effort à tous
les Français.
Enfin, il est hors de question que
l'Etat s'empare des réserves du
privé.
L'argent des retraites doit aller
aux retraités et à eux seuls.
Par-dessus tout, il faut réparer
une injustice.
2 millions de retraités ont cotisé
toute leur vie, ils ont travaillé
dur, ils ont des
carrières complètes, ils
perçoivent aujourd'hui une
retraite indigne autour de 900
euros par mois.
C'est indigne d'un grand pays
comme le nôtre.
Etes-vous prêts à leur garantir
une retraite minimum de 1200
euros?
Je vous le dis clairement, c'est
pour nous une condition
impérative.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
Applaudissements
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le président Olivier
Marleix, je voudrais profiter de
cette première question
d'actualité pour souhaiter mes
meilleurs voeux à l'ensemble des
députés, à leurs collaborateurs et
aux services de l'Assemblée
nationale.
Vous nous interrogez sur notre
projet pour les retraites.
Vous le comprendrez, les quelques
minutes qui me sont accordées dans
le cadre de ces questions
d'actualité ne vont pas me
permettre de vous exposer la
totalité de ce projet, mais vous
aurez l'occasion d'en débattre
très rapidement.
Je sais combien le sujet des
petites pensions vous tient à
coeur et importe à votre groupe.
Nous en avons parlé à de
nombreuses reprises lors de nos
rencontres depuis octobre pour
préparer le projet de réforme des
retraites.
Vous le savez, j'ai eu l'occasion
de le dire: cette préoccupation,
je la partage.
Mon gouvernement la partage.
Le président de la République
avait pris l'engagement de porter
le montant de la pension minimale
à 85% du SMIC pour une carrière
complète, soit bientôt 1200 euros
par mois.
Dans quelques heures, je serai
amenée à présenter notre projet
pour les retraites, mais je vous
le confirme: l'engagement du
président sera tenu.
C'est un progrès social important,
attendu, et vous l'avez souligné,
il y a des personnes qui touchent
de petites pensions.
60% sont des femmes qui ont
souvent eu des carrières
incomplètes.
Ce sont aussi des indépendants,
des artisans, des commerçants, qui
ont passé une vie de travail sans
pouvoir se verser un salaire
suffisant.
Nous avons également échangé ces
derniers jours sur la situation
des retraités qui, après une vie
de travail, avec un revenu
modeste, touchent aujourd'hui de
très petites pensions.
Je vous confirme que j'ai bien
entendu la demande de votre
groupe.
Nous partageons cette
préoccupation, une carrière
complète doit permettre d'avoir
une pension digne.
J'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir
tout à l'heure.
Nous sommes prêts à y travailler.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Clémence
Guetté pour le groupe La France
Insoumise.
- Clémence Guetté: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, après
avoir juré de ne pas toucher à
l'âge de la retraite, monsieur
Macron a un nouveau projet, la
retraite à 64 ans.
Pour combler le déficit à venir,
pas de cotisations sur les
dividendes ou sur les très hauts
salaires.
Il vous faut continuer à empiler
les cadeaux fiscaux, même si, au
passage, vous allez faire bondir
les dépenses pour financer le RSA,
et le chômage.
Aujourd'hui, à 62 ans, celles et
ceux qui ne sont pas encore à la
retraite sont déjà 40% à ne plus
travailler.
Demain, ils seront plus nombreux
encore à être malades, cassés par
le travail, au chômage de longue
durée.
Grâce à l'appui de la droite, vous
prévoyez d'enlever de la vie à ces
gens.
Ce sont 15.000 personnes de plus
qui vont mourir chaque année avant
la retraite.
Tout cela dissipe le flou sur vos
intentions.
Pour une aide-soignante mère de
deux enfants qui a commencé à 21
ans, deux ans de plus.
Le couperet que vous allez faire
tomber va s'abattre sur des
familles et sur des vies.
Vous voulez pour cela passer en
force.
Vous prévoyez déjà un 49.3.
Les organisations de jeunesse nous
donnent rendez-vous le 21 janvier.
Les trois quarts des Français
expriment clairement leur volonté:
la retraite à 60 ans, du temps
libéré pour soi, pour les siens,
pour les autres.
C'est le sens du progrès social
qui se combine aujourd'hui à
l'urgence écologique vers la
réduction du temps de travail.
Madame la Première ministre,
renoncez.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Madame la
présidente, mesdames et messieurs
les députés, madame la députée
Clémence Guetté, vous demandez
s'il y a urgence.
Oui, il y a urgence.
Le rapport du COR et des
partenaires sociaux montre que dès
2027, ce sont plusieurs millions
de déficits.
En 2035, ce sera 20 milliards
d'euros.
Si vous considérez qu'il n'y a pas
urgence, c'est parce que vous
acceptez le risque de casser le
système de retraite pour nos
enfants, de leur léguer un système
de protection sociale au rabais.
Nous considérons que l'équilibre
est nécessaire.
Nous considérons que le premier
rail de protection, de solidarité,
c'est de sauver le système par
répartition.
Le deuxième point que vous avez
évoqué, ce sont les mesures que
nous allons annoncer tout à
l'heure.
Vous parlez sans savoir et sans
penser.
Vous êtes le seul groupe à n'avoir
formulé aucune proposition, aucune
alternative, à ne pas avoir
participé aux concertations et à
ne pas avoir joué le jeu du
dialogue républicain.
Nous allons mener cette réforme
pour les Français, pour nos
enfants, nos petits-enfants, et
nous n'allons pas sombrer dans la
démagogie qui est la vôtre.
La retraite à 60 ans, c'est 85
milliards d'euros par an.
Où est-ce que vous les prenez?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Eric
Woerth pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Eric Woerth: Monsieur le
ministre du Travail, aujourd'hui
est un jour important.
Le gouvernement va présenter le
contenu de la réforme des
retraites.
C'est une réforme au service de
notre modèle social.
Alors que cela se tiendra
aujourd'hui, il nous faut apporter
des réponses solides pour protéger
le système par répartition qui est
l'expression d'une solidarité
intergénérationnelle.
Cette réforme doit être efficace.
Lorsque l'on parle de retraite,
chacun pense immédiatement à
l'âge.
Refuser de parler de l'âge, ce
serait éclipser le débat, un peu
comme si on parlait de mariage
sans parler d'amour.
Gouverner, c'est affronter la
réalité.
Cette réforme doit être efficace,
mais elle doit être juste.
La retraite est le reflet
du parcours professionnel et
familial de chacun.
Au sein du système de retraite, il
existe une multitude de
dispositifs qui viennent adoucir
les inégalités accumulées tout au
long d'une carrière
professionnelle.
Cependant, ce n'est pas au seul
régime des retraites de résoudre
les injustices de la vie.
Il faut les résoudre avant.
Seule la prévention permettra de
réduire l'usure physique au
travail.
Une réforme des retraites, c'est
d'abord une réforme de société.
Augmenter l'âge de départ, c'est
changer le regard de notre société
sur le travail.
Le rôle de chaque entreprise est
fondamental.
Le degré d'implication des
entreprises dans la durée
conditionne le succès de la
réforme et les pouvoirs publics
devront accompagner les
entreprises pour qu'elles puissent
le faire.
Je n'ai aucun doute que le
dialogue avec les entreprises soit
aujourd'hui fructueux.
Je voudrais simplement pouvoir
avec vous le vérifier.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
Monsieur Eric Woerth, votre
question me permet de souligner
l'importance qu'il y a à mener
cette réforme pour établir
l'équilibre du régime de retraite.
J'ai eu l'occasion de le dire à
maintes reprises.
L'équilibrer sans l'améliorer
serait injuste.
C'est l'amélioration et
l'équilibre que nous recherchons.
Nous le faisons avec le dialogue
social et avec les partenaires
sociaux.
Nous avons construit des
convergences.
Nous avons aussi acté un certain
nombre de désaccords.
La transparence du dialogue social
recommande aussi de dire lorsqu'il
y a un désaccord ou un différend.
Nous construisons un système qui
permet de mieux prendre en compte
l'emploi des seniors.
Nous pouvons construire des
indicateurs, faciliter les
transitions, mais pour que
l'emploi des seniors soit au
rendez-vous, il faut aussi un
changement dans l'attitude des
dirigeants qui dirigent les
ressources humaines pour que les
seniors soient vus comme un atout
plutôt qu'un coût salarial.
Nous avons aussi parlé des
questions de pénibilité.
Là aussi, nous voulons retenir le
dialogue social comme méthode pour
permettre la mise en place de
plans de prévention qui soient des
plans massifs permettant à des
salariés d'aller jusqu'au bout de
leur carrière, sans être abîmés
par leur travail, sans être cassés
et devoir partir plus tôt.
Nous faisons aussi en sorte de
mobiliser les entreprises pour que
l'ensemble de cette réforme puisse
être mené avec la progressivité
nécessaire et la volonté de
retrouver un équilibre.
Nous le faisons en cohérence avec
la politique économique qui est la
nôtre.
Ce que nous mettons en oeuvre
comme réforme des retraites, c'est
une réforme qui n'est pas une
politique de compétitivité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
au président monsieur André
Chassaigne.
- André Chassaigne: Madame la
Première ministre, vous allez nous
annoncer dans quelques heures le
contenu de votre réforme des
retraites, négociée avec Les
Républicains, une réforme brutale,
une réforme de droite.
Vous prétextez pour la justifier
"une urgence", "la faillite de
notre régime de retraite".
Quelle urgence?
Un déficit pour les 10 années à
venir qui, loin de mettre en péril
notre régime de retraite, pourrait
être facilement résorbé.
Rien sur le plan économique ne
justifie un recul de l'âge de
départ à la retraite!
Rien, sauf votre enfermement
idéologique.
Nous vous demandons de renoncer à
votre texte qui pénalisera tous
les travailleurs et qui aggravera
les injustices existantes.
Si vous persistez en dépit du bon
sens, nous n'osons imaginer que
vous nous empêcherez d'en
débattre, que vous nous empêcherez
de faire des propositions pour
améliorer notre système de
retraite par répartition.
C'est pourtant ce que vous ferez
si vous choisissez de présenter
votre réforme!
Une manoeuvre grossière, un ennemi
de la démocratie, une manoeuvre
permettant de profiter des délais
constitutionnels imposés par son
examen et ainsi empêcher les
oppositions de mettre en débat
leurs propositions de réforme sous
peine de voir votre projet mis en
oeuvre par ordonnance.
Il faudra l'expliquer aux
Françaises et aux Français.
Il faudra l'assumer, leur dire que
vous leur refusez le temps du
débat démocratique car vous en
avez peur, vous avez peur de
l'opposition unanime, de tous les
syndicats et de près de 85% de la
population.
Cette confiscation du débat serait
un nouveau coup, un coup terrible
pour notre démocratie.
A rebours, nous portons l'étendard
de la démocratie pour décider de
l'avenir de nos retraites.
Renoncez à votre réforme ou, à
défaut, nous porterons l'exigence
d'un référendum.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci.
Monsieur le président Chassaigne,
je pense que nous pouvons être
d'accord sur un point: la retraite
par répartition est au coeur de
notre contrat social.
Elle est au fondement de la
solidarité entre les générations.
Mais aujourd'hui, comme le montre
le rapport du Conseil
d'Orientation des Retraites, et
comme le constatent nos
concitoyens eux-mêmes, le nombre
d'actifs par rapport au nombre de
retraités ne cesse de diminuer.
Cela a des conséquences que chacun
connaît: les déficits s'accumulent
et nous devons agir vite.
C'est bien ce que le président de
la République a porté lors de sa
campagne.
Nous avons été clairs avec les
Français.
Depuis des mois, nous menons une
concertation intense avec le
ministre Olivier Dussopt, avec les
partenaires sociaux.
Tous ont participé aux échanges.
J'ai rencontré à plusieurs
reprises les présidents de tous
les groupes parlementaires.
Je voudrais vous remercier,
monsieur le président Chassaigne,
comme l'ensemble de vos collègues
à l'Assemblée et au Sénat, car
chacune de nos rencontres a été
utile pour faire progresser le
projet.
Nous avons montré par le passé que
nous pouvions trouver des points
d'accord.
Nous l'avons vu sur votre
proposition de loi pour
revaloriser les retraites
agricoles.
Avec le ministre Olivier Dussopt,
nous aurons l'occasion de
présenter notre projet pour les
retraites dans les prochaines
heures.
Je voudrais revenir sur quelques
grands principes.
Nous voulons un projet qui finance
les retraites, et rien d'autre que
les retraites.
Nous refusons d'augmenter le coût
du travail ou des impôts.
Nous refusons de baisser les
pensions.
Au contraire, nous voulons les
augmenter.
Nous voulons un retour à
l'équilibre de notre système à
l'horizon 2030.
C'est pourquoi, pour l'avenir de
nos retraites, nous devrons
progressivement travailler plus
longtemps, mais ce n'est pas tout.
Nous portons un projet de justice.
En tenant compte des carrières
longues, de la pénibilité de
certains métiers, en s'assurant
que les mêmes métiers donnent la
même retraite, nous défendons un
projet porteur de progrès social.
Nous augmenterons la pension
minimale pour les futurs retraités
à près de 1200 euros nets par
mois.
Nous redonnerons toute leur place
aux salariés proches de la
retraite dans les entreprises.
Comme je l'ai déjà indiqué, ce
projet de loi sera présenté le 23
janvier.
Il sera ensuite débattu dans votre
assemblée.
Je note que les députés de la
NUPES ont beaucoup parlé de
démocratie ces dernières semaines.
J'espère que les actes suivront
les mots.
J'espère que le débat pourra se
dérouler dans les meilleures
conditions.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame la
présidente madame Marine Le Pen
pour le groupe Rassemblement
National.
- Marine Le Pen: Ma question
s'adresse à la Première ministre.
Il y a un an, lorsque vous étiez
ministre du Travail, vous avez
commandé le rapport RL, pour la
reconnaissance des métiers de
deuxième ligne.
Ces métiers que l'on ne peut pas
exercer à distance et sur lesquels
la France s'est reposée durant la
crise Covid.
Cela concerne par exemple les
boulangers ou les charcutiers.
Cela concerne des métiers
essentiels à la vie de la nation.
Comme le rappelle Franceinfo, 80%
des boulangers risquent la
faillite.
C'est désormais en première ligne
que vous les laissez seuls face
aux prix de l'énergie.
Cela devrait être à vous d'être en
première ligne pour renégocier les
clauses du marché européen de
l'énergie en dissociant le prix du
gaz de celui de l'électricité.
A l'image de nos boulangers, plus
largement de nos artisans et
commerçants, en ce début d'année,
une grande partie de nos
compatriotes sont fatigués.
1 Français sur 2 se dit "révolté"
face à la situation économique du
pays.
Près de 8 Français sur 10
craignent une révolte sociale.
Dans ce contexte, pensez-vous
sincèrement qu'il est bon pour le
pays de débuter cette année en
nous proposant tout à l'heure une
réforme des retraites en vue de
décaler l'âge de départ à la
retraite à laquelle 70% Français
sont opposés?
Le gouvernement parle de
"courage", mais ce n'est pas du
courage de faire payer aux
Français, et en particulier à ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler tôt.
Pour pérenniser notre modèle de
retraite, il faut d'une part
relancer la natalité et d'autre
part créer des emplois de qualité
pour enfin relancer la
productivité de notre économie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la présidente Marine Le
Pen, je vous le confirme, notre
objectif, l'objectif de mon
gouvernement, c'est de protéger
les Français face à la hausse des
prix de l'énergie.
C'est le sens du bouclier
tarifaire.
C'est le sens des mesures pour les
entreprises et pour les
collectivités que nous avons
portées dès cet été dans
ce lieu, pour le pouvoir d'achat
et dans les textes financiers
adoptés à la fin de l'année.
Je note que le Rassemblement
National a voté contre tous ces
textes.
Malgré le Rassemblement National,
nous pouvons proposer un
amortisseur pour baisser la
facture d'électricité des Français
dans le cadre de la loi de
finances.
Nous pouvons proposer des aides
financées dans la marge dégagée
par les fournisseurs d'énergie, et
c'est ce que nous faisons.
Le ministre de l'Economie a
rappelé l'ensemble des dispositifs
qui sont mis en oeuvre pour
protéger nos boulangers, nos
artisans, nos très petites
entreprises.
Dès cette semaine, nos artisans
peuvent s'adresser aux préfectures
pour avoir accès à l'ensemble des
aides qui permettent de prendre en
charge jusqu'à 40% de la hausse
des factures d'électricité.
Tous ceux dont les tarifs sont
supérieurs à 280 euros par
mégawatt heure auront une aide
supplémentaire.
Nous protégeons notre économie,
nous protégeons les Français
aujourd'hui, mais nous protégeons
aussi l'avenir des Français,
l'avenir de nos retraites et c'est
le sens du projet.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Marie Lebec.
- Marie Lebec: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre, alors que la
conjoncture économique reste
difficile, avec la guerre en
Ukraine, la réouverture économique
désordonnée de la Chine ou
l'instabilité des prix de
l'énergie, notre économie résiste.
Les résultats sont là.
Nous avons eu une croissance
positive.
300.000 emplois ont été créés sur
les trois premiers trimestres de
2022.
C'est grâce à l'engagement de
tous.
Au premier rang: nos entrepreneurs
et leurs salariés.
Je salue leur résilience, alors
que le contexte national, européen
et international, aurait pu les
empêcher d'innover.
L'annonce la semaine dernière par
le président de la République et
sa volonté de s'appuyer sur notre
réseau de préfecture a été saluée
par les acteurs économiques.
Ils ont été très réactifs pendant
la crise du Covid.
Le bouclier énergétique mis en
place par notre majorité a fait
partie des réponses.
Cela a protégé la grande majorité
de nos PME.
Néanmoins, aucun de nous, sur ces
bancs, n'a été sourd aux appels de
nos boulangers et de nos artisans,
quant aux difficultés qu'ils
rencontrent.
Ils sont parfois les derniers
acteurs économiques de nos
centres-villes.
Depuis plusieurs années, vous avez
engagé une bataille en faveur de
la réindustrialisation de notre
pays.
La France est redevenue le premier
pays européen en termes
d'attractivité.
Par ailleurs, nous croyons, dans
la majorité comme au gouvernement,
en la capacité de notre industrie
à devenir verte.
L'ensemble des acteurs économiques
doivent être mobilisés pour agir
en faveur de la réussite
économique de notre pays.
Si ces batailles économiques sont
des défis pour les années à venir,
nous ne devons pas oublier nos
bons résultats.
Quelles sont les perspectives
économiques pour 2023?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Bruno Le
Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Madame la
députée Lebec, avant la coupure de
Noël, certains nous expliquaient
que nous allions entrer en
récession.
On nous expliquait que la
production industrielle allait
s'effondrer et que le chômage
allait repartir à la hausse, et
que nous aurions des coupures
d'électricité cet hiver.
Oui, c'était vous.
Le résultat,
c'est qu'aujourd'hui, nous avons
une croissance de 2,5% en 2022.
La croissance en 2023 sera
positive.
L'indice de la production
industrielle a été positif
également.
Il n'y a pas eu de coupures
d'électricité.
Les ingénieurs, les ouvriers, les
salariés d'EDF ont remis
aujourd'hui en état les 45 GW
qu'ils avaient promis pour le
premier 1er janvier.
Oui, la France résiste et
l'économie résiste.
La croissance française résiste,
même mieux que ses partenaires.
Il faut poursuivre dans cette
dynamique.
Nous proposons dans les mois qui
viennent un projet de loi de
réindustrialisation des énergies
vertes.
C'est la première fois que la
France recrée des emplois
industriels depuis des décennies.
Avec ce projet de loi, nous allons
accélérer cette industrialisation
de la France pour en faire la
première nation décarbonée de
l'Union Européenne.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Arthur
Delaporte.
- Arthur Delaporte: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
C'est histoire d'un projet de
décret sur l'assurance-chômage
transmis aux partenaires sociaux
le 23 décembre.
C'est l'histoire de votre mépris
du dialogue social.
Mais c'est aussi l'histoire
secrète de votre secret espoir
qu'un plus grand durcissement de
votre réforme passe inaperçu.
Vous vouliez réduire quasiment de
moitié l'indemnisation.
Dans le contexte économique que
nous connaissons, vous étiez prêts
à sacrifier un nombre important de
nos concitoyens.
Joli cadeau de Noël.
Mais vous avez fait ensuite
semblant de reculer pour mieux
conserver votre terrible réforme.
Elle est antisociale et violente.
Elle doit entrer en oeuvre dans
trois semaines.
Une baisse de 25% des droits.
Six mois de moins pour les
travailleurs de moins de 55 ans.
Votre baisse va s'appliquer de
manière encore plus violente pour
les seniors, ces travailleurs en
fin de carrière.
Avec votre réforme des retraites,
c'est la double peine.
Moins d'indemnités et plus de
précarité.
Mais avec le recul de l'âge de
départ que vous promettez, c'est
aussi plus de seniors sans
allocations-chômage, alors que 1
personne sur 2 de plus de 55 ans
est sans emploi.
Il faudra subir deux ans de plus
pour toucher une retraite réduite.
Le chômeur cotise pour sa
retraite.
Celui qui n'a pas d'allocations ne
cotise pas.
Vous proposez donc plus de
précarité.
58.000 personnes ont été rasées de
Pôle emploi.
Il n'est pas trop tard pour plus
de justice.
Il faut abroger
l'assurance-chômage et votre
projet de retraite.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, la
parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Vous trouvez
parfois satisfaisante une
situation dans laquelle un
Français sur deux de plus de 55
ans est sans emploi.
Nous menons une politique
d'emplois.
Elle porte ses fruits.
119.000 emplois nets ont été
créés.
Entre le mois d'octobre 2021 et le
mois d'octobre 2022, la formation
des demandeurs d'emploi a permis
de raccompagner vers l'emploi
380.000 demandeurs d'emploi de
longue durée.
C'est une bonne nouvelle pour eux
et les entreprises.
Notre taux de chômage est
historiquement bas.
Nous intégrons la conjoncture
économique dans la définition des
règles d'indemnisation, avec des
règles plus incitatives quand il y
a des tensions de recrutement.
Nous avons prolongé les droits au
chômage pendant la période du
Covid.
Nous avions mis en place une année
blanche pour les intermittents du
spectacle.
Nous avons un décret en cours
d'examen qui sera en vigueur en
février.
Nous avons dit aux partenaires
sociaux notre volonté pour que ce
mouvement aille plus loin.
Nous avons un nombre de chantiers
devant nous.
Le premier, c'est la gouvernance
de l'assurance-chômage.
Dans quelques semaines, je
laisserai le document
d'orientation aux partenaires
sociaux pour qu'ils puissent
l'étudier.
Nous pourrons ensuite saisir à
nouveau les partenaires sociaux
pour parler des modalités
d'indemnisation à partir de 2024.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Frédéric
Valletoux.
- Frédéric Valletoux: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
François Braun.
Vendredi dernier, le président a
lancé le grand chantier de la
réforme de notre système de santé,
un chantier aux multiples
facettes, mais dont la nécessité
n'est plus à démontrer.
Nous le voyons tous les jours sur
le terrain.
Les hospitaliers sont aux
premières loges de ces
difficultés.
Après un effort inédit sur les
rémunérations et la relance de
l'investissement hospitalier, il
faut refonder un système de santé
en crise.
Parmi les principaux objectifs: la
question de la remise à plat de
son financement, pour sortir de la
tarification à l'activité mais
aussi pour revaloriser la
pertinence des soins.
En septembre 2018, le président
avait rappelé, avec une réforme de
santé, que 30% des dépenses de
santé étaient des dépenses
inutiles ou non-pertinentes.
Il y a des excès.
A l'hôpital, la tarification
représente la moitié des
financements.
Dans le secteur privé, ça paraît
encore plus élevé.
La France consacre 270 milliards
d'euros à ses dépenses de santé.
Avec 30% de cela, il y a largement
de quoi financer les consultations
des généralistes.
Percutée par la crise sanitaire,
cette réforme de financement n'a
pas été faite, mais elle arrive
enfin et tant mieux.
En remplacement de la tarification
à l'activité, quel modèle de
financement envisagez-vous pour la
pérennité de notre système de
santé?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur François
Braun, ministre de la Santé.
- François Braun: Mesdames et
messieurs, monsieur le député
Frédéric Valletoux, le discours du
6 janvier du président de la
République devant les soignants
marque un changement de méthode et
d'analyse par rapport aux
problèmes de notre système de
santé.
Il a été construit sur l'offre de
soins, qui est concurrentielle par
définition et qui s'appuie sur un
financement à l'acte.
Le changement de cap, c'est
retravailler notre système de
santé sur la base de la réponse
aux besoins de santé de la
population.
Il faut simplifier, décloisonner,
valoriser, mais valoriser à la
réalisation des missions de santé
publique de chaque partenaire.
Au niveau de l'hôpital, il faut
revenir à l'échelle du service, en
tout cas pour les services qui le
souhaitent, il faut revenir à une
taille humaine.
Le partage de la pénibilité de la
nuit doit être réalisé entre tous
les partenaires.
Il n'est pas normal que l'un des
partenaires supporte seul toute la
pénibilité des gardes.
Nous allons mettre en place un
suivi de la carrière de l'ensemble
des soignants, pour que, quand on
entre comme infirmière dans un
hôpital, on ait des perspectives
d'avenir.
Il faut peut-être aller vers des
responsabilités et reconnaître ces
compétences.
Il faut créer de nouveaux métiers
avec des compétences avancées.
La coopération territoriale va
être la base de cette refonte du
système de santé.
Le partage des compétences, le
partage des missions entre les
partenaires.
C'est valable aussi pour le
financement.
Nous passons de cette logique de
financement de l'offre à un
financement de réponse aux
besoins, pour répondre aux besoins
de chaque territoire.
Il faut mettre de l'humain, du bon
sens dans les organisations et
dans les financements.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Philippe
Lottiaux.
- Philippe Lottiaux: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre de
l'Education nationale.
Notre pays éprouve des
difficultés.
Tel était le constate du candidat
Emmanuel Macron 2017.
L'évaluation récente des élèves
entrant en sixième en septembre
2022 vous ont amené à reconnaître
que les comparaisons
internationales révèlent des
lacunes préoccupantes.
Cette évaluation illustre que plus
du quart des élèves maîtrise mal
ou très mal le français.
Plus du tiers, les mathématiques.
Le niveau constaté en France ne
fait que baisser.
Il se situe sensiblement en-deçà
de la moyenne européenne et de
l'OCDE.
Les élèves entrant en sixième en
septembre sont ceux qui rentraient
en cours préparatoire en septembre
2017.
Le constat s'impose de lui-même.
La présidence d'Emmanuel Macron
est celle de l'affaissement de
l'école républicaine.
Une école gangrenée par le
wokisme, par une pédagogie
hasardeuse, par la repentance des
principes d'éducation.
Il faut transmettre, transmettre
un savoir et des principes
fondamentaux.
La preuve en est le creusement des
inégalités sociales.
L'esprit des lumières ne brille
plus dans l'enseignement primaire.
Vous reconnaissez que l'accent
doit être mis sur les savoirs
fondamentaux.
Que proposez-vous?
Un renforcement de
l'accompagnement des élèves de
sixième.
Mais il faut prévoir quelque chose
pour le CP et le CE2.
Il faut éviter que la dégradation
de l'école se poursuive.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Pap
Ndiaye.
- Pap Ndiaye: Mesdames et
messieurs, madame la présidente,
monsieur le député Philippe
Lottiaux, en effet, il faut le
dire, j'ai indiqué que les
résultats de nos élèves, en ce qui
concerne les savoirs fondamentaux,
ne sont pas à la hauteur.
Cela comprend également les années
précédentes, avec la crise
sanitaire qui a impacté les
résultats de l'école primaire.
Pour remédier à cette situation
que nous reconnaissons, j'ai
annoncé des mesures fortes.
Au primaire: des recommandations
cette semaine vont être adressées
aux professeurs
et aux inspecteurs, afin que
soient instaurées partout, dans la
foulée de l'inspection générale,
la pratique régulière de la
dictée, la pratique quotidienne de
la rédaction, le temps
hebdomadaire d'écriture étant
insuffisant en cours moyen.
Il y aura aussi la régularité du
calcul mental.
Au collège, nous agissons dès la
rentrée prochaine en sixième, en
facilitant la transition entre le
primaire et le secondaire, pour
s'attaquer immédiatement aux
difficultés des élèves, afin
qu'elles ne pèsent pas sur
l'ensemble de la scolarité au
collège.
Chaque élève a bénéficié d'une
heure de soutien en français et en
mathématiques, assurée par les
professeurs des écoles en sixième,
pour remédier à ces difficultés.
Le dispositif sera rendu
obligatoire pour tous les élèves
de sixième.
Il y aura l'obligation de 1h30 de
mathématiques pour les élèves de
première.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Sophie
Taillé-Polian.
- Sophie Taillé-Polian: Merci.
Dans son rapport, en septembre
dernier, le Conseil d'Orientation
des Retraites écrit clairement
qu'il n'y a pas d'urgence.
Notre système de retraites, joyau
de notre protection sociale, n'est
pas en danger.
Essayer de convaincre les Français
d'avaler votre recul des retraites
au nom d'un soi-disant sauvetage
du système, c'est leur mentir.
Vous êtes obsédés
pour trouver qui va payer le quoi
qu'il en coûte.
Avec vous, le peuple doit payer.
Vous allez fragiliser le plus
grand nombre.
Les Français sont obsédés par
cette réforme à 80%.
Vous allez faire perdre à tous
deux ou trois ans de retraite.
Il n'y a aucune urgence à réformer
notre système, si ce n'est pour
l'améliorer.
De multiples pistes sont sur la
table pour cela.
Le choix qui s'annonce de faire
passer cette régression via un
PLFSS ER est un nouveau palier que
vous franchissez.
Ce n'est pas le cas ici!
Vous choisissez cette option pour
limiter le débat parlementaire.
Cette procédure ouvre la
possibilité de passer par
ordonnance en cas d'enlisement.
C'est un détournement de l'esprit
de la Constitution.
Il faut renoncer à cette méthode
et à cette réforme.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
Madame la députée Sophie
Taillé-Polian, vous nous demandez
s'il y a urgence, oui.
Le rapport du Conseil
d'Orientation des Retraites,
composé des partenaires sociaux,
pose trois constats.
Premier constat: à la fin de
années 70, nous avions trois
cotisants pour un retraité.
Au début des années 2000, nous
avions deux cotisants pour un
retraité.
En 2040, nous aurons 1,4 cotisant
pour un retraité.
C'est ça, le problème
démographique.
Cela explique le déficit constaté.
Deuxième constat, vous l'avez
vous-même cité, que dit le
rapport?
Il dit que le système est
légèrement excédentaire cette
année.
Il dit que dès 2023, ce système
sera déficitaire.
En 2027, c'est 12,5 milliards de
déficit par an.
C'est 15 milliards d'euros en
2030.
C'est 25 milliards en 2040.
Si vous pensez que cela n'est
rien, nous n'avons pas la même
conception des choses.
Enfin, le rapport dit que si nous
ne faisons rien, le niveau de vie
des retraités va s'effondrer.
Vous voulez retrouver la situation
des années 70?
Les retraités étaient les pauvres
de ce pays.
Nous menons cette réforme pour
éviter cela.
Nous voulons éviter que les
carrières des plus fragiles, les
carrières des femmes, soient mieux
protégées.
C'est important de l'améliorer.
Nous équilibrerons parce que c'est
raisonnable.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Charlotte
Parmentier-Lecocq.
- Charlotte Parmentier-Lecocq:
Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de la Santé et de la
Prévention.
Lors de ses voeux aux acteurs de
la santé, le président de la
République a annoncé la fin
espérée de la tarification à
l'acte.
La même qui a provoqué une
désorganisation majeure de nos
hôpitaux, en faisant primer la
rentabilité sur l'intérêt des
patients.
Je salue cette initiative, qui
s'inscrit dans l'action de notre
majorité.
Elle s'ajoutera à la suppression
du numerus clausus, mais également
à la revalorisation de la
rémunération et l'augmentation du
nombre de soignants.
Nous devons poursuivre sur cette
voie.
Je salue la proposition de loi de
notre collègue qui apporte une
avancée supplémentaire, en
permettant l'accès direct aux
infirmiers en pratique avancée,
aux masseurs kinésithérapeutes, à
accéder à de nouveaux métiers.
Tous les professionnels de santé
sont unanimes.
Il faut tailler à la hache dans
les lourdeurs administratives qui
alourdissent leur travail.
Les soignants et les patients
comptent sur nous.
Quelles sont vos échéances dans la
concrétisation de la feuille de
route tracée par le président?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur François
Braun.
- François Braun: Mesdames et
messieurs, madame la députée
Parmentier-Lecocq, le 6 janvier,
le président a tracé une feuille
de route pour la Refondation de
notre système de santé.
Beaucoup a déjà été fait, mais
nous devons aller plus vite.
Il faut régler les problèmes à
l'échelle de chaque territoire,
sortir d'une logique
concurrentielle et coopérer,
retrouver du collectif à échelle
humaine.
Il faut redonner du temps médical
et du temps de soin.
La disparition trop tardive du
numerus clausus n'aura d'effet que
dans 5 à 10 ans.
Il faut laisser les soignants
faire ce pour quoi ils ont été
formés.
En ville, il faut développer les
assistants médicaux.
A l'hôpital, il faut intégrer des
administratifs, des logisticiens
auprès des soignants.
Il faut utiliser les compétences
de chacun, la plus-value de chaque
professionnel, notamment au sein
d'une équipe qui travaillera
autour du médecin traitant.
Nous allons continuer à
travailler.
Ce sont des engagements clairs
pour les Français.
Un médecin traitant pour tous ceux
qui en ont le plus besoin.
Une continuité des soins sur tout
le territoire.
Ce sont des engagements clairs des
professionnels de santé.
Enfin, il faut construire des
pactes avec les élus pour
l'attractivité des territoires sur
les logements, les crèches et les
transports.
Les échéances sont courtes.
L'enjeu est majeur: mars 2023 pour
la fin des négociations avec les
médecins.
L'important, ce sont des résultats
réels auprès des Français et des
soignants.
Je suis déterminé pour avancer en
ce sens.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Charlotte Parmentier-Lecocq:
Comme il me reste un peu de temps,
permettez-moi de vous convier à la
maison de santé où, grâce à
l'engagement des soignants, des
acteurs économiques, du maire de
la commune, nous inaugurons
prochainement l'implantation du
premier scanner en France, au sein
d'une maison de santé.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan.
- Nicolas Dupont-Aignan: Ma
question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
Trois crises angoissent en cette
rentrée nos concitoyens.
Sur chacune d'entre elles, la
santé, le prix de l'électricité
et, les retraites...
Vous soufflez sur les braises.
Vous refusez de prendre des
décisions.
Vous annoncez 6000 assistants
médicaux fantômes.
Vous refusez de réintégrer les
soignants qui pourraient être au
chevet des malades.
Sur le prix de l'électricité, on a
multiplié les dispositifs
complexes, bureaucratiques, alors
qu'il faudrait, comme en Espagne
ou au Portugal, revenir à un prix
national, aligné sur les coûts de
production, qui permettrait de
sauver nos PME et nos artisans.
Sur les retraites, vous allez
plonger dans la misère bon nombre
de seniors qui n'auront pas
d'emploi, entre 62 et 64 ans, qui
seront aux minima sociaux...
Tout ça pour quelques milliards en
2030, alors que vous refusez de
vous attaquer aux dizaines de
milliards de fraudes fiscales, aux
versements de l'Union Européenne,
au coût de l'immigration
clandestine.
Pourquoi continuer à mettre
d'huile sur le feu, à faire
souffrir les Français, à diviser
la nation?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs, en ce début
d'année, vous l'avez dit, certains
parmi nous ont fait des voeux et
d'autres ont pris de bonnes
résolutions.
En 2023, ce ne sera pas l'année au
cours de laquelle vous arrêterez
la démagogie.
J'aime répondre sur le fond aux
questions qui sont posées.
Vous avez fait un mélange de
plusieurs idées complotistes.
Vous parlez de la réintégration
des soignants non-vaccinés et des
retraites.
Ce qui est sûr, c'est que les
crises angoissent les Français.
Presque tous les Français, pas
vous.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur Nicolas Dupont-Aignan?
- Nicolas Dupont-Aignan: Monsieur
le ministre n'est pas choqué qu'un
boulanger ait un contrat à 50
euros ou 100 euros et que cela
passe à 280 euros?
Vous mettez la tête des Français
sous l'eau.
Ensuite, vous les repêchez et vous
attendez qu'ils vous remercient.
Vous êtes hypocrites.
Vous les méprisez.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre?
- Bénédicte Taurine: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de l'Economie.
Depuis plusieurs mois, nous sommes
toutes et tous alertés sur
l'augmentation des prix de
l'énergie dans des secteurs aussi
diversifiés que celui de
l'artisanat, avec notamment une
mobilisation inédite des
boulangers et des bouchers, celui
de l'entreprise ou des
collectivités territoriales.
Votre gouvernement a mis en oeuvre
diverses mesures.
Je pense par exemple au chèque
énergie et au bouclier tarifaire.
Vous les avez déjà évoqués au
cours de cette séance.
Malheureusement, ce que l'on peut
constater, c'est que cela laisse
un certain nombre de personnes sur
le bord du chemin.
Un simple exemple: 80% des
boulangers, selon leur
confédération, ne seraient pas
éligibles au bouclier tarifaire.
Concernant les entreprises, pour
65.000 d'entre elles, l'impact de
la hausse des coûts va faire
basculer le résultat en négatif.
Quant à la majorité des
copropriétés ou des 600.000
logements sociaux qui sont
chauffés par un système collectif
alimenté par du gaz ou de
l'électricité, depuis la
libéralisation des marchés de
l'énergie, ces chauffages
collectifs ne peuvent plus
bénéficier des tarifs réglementés.
Le mécanisme de compensation qui a
été mis en place est défaillant et
il n'empêche pas les hausses de
charge spectaculaires que nous
pouvons tous constater sur nos
circonscriptions.
Monsieur le ministre, plutôt que
de mettre en place au cas par cas
des mesures qui, au final, sont
peu lisibles, qui laissent des
situations sans solution et qui
divisent les Français, pouvez-vous
nous expliquer pour quelles
raisons vous ne prenez pas une
mesure unique, simple et juste à
la fois pour les ménages, les
entreprises et les collectivités
qui pourraient remettre en place
le tarif réglementé?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Roland Lescure.
- Roland Lescure: Merci.
Madame la députée, merci de votre
question.
Vous le savez, je pense que tout
le monde le sait: la France et
l'Europe font face à un choc
énergétique exceptionnel.
Ce que vous proposez d'instaurer,
un bouclier énergétique pour
l'ensemble des acteurs
économiques, c'est tout simplement
un coût exorbitant, de l'argent
magique, le retour de "Quoi qu'il
en coûte" dans des situations où
ce ne serait pas justifié.
Vous avez parlé de 80.000
boulangers au bord de la faillite.
Nous avons annoncé un certain
nombre de mesures en accord avec
les distributeurs d'énergie pour
un plafonnement du tarif pour les
boulangers et l'ensemble des TPE.
Certains verront leur facture
plafonnée à 280 euros le mégawatt
heure.
Nous avons aussi adopté des
mesures pour les grands groupes
industriels qui consomment
beaucoup d'énergie et pour les
PME.
Bruno Le Maire a eu l'occasion de
le rappeler tout à l'heure: la
France est le pays qui s'en sort
le mieux aujourd'hui en Europe.
La production industrielle est en
hausse, le chômage est en baisse,
les prévisions de croissance
plaident encore pour une
croissance positive en 2022 alors
qu'elle sera négative à peu près
partout en Europe.
Tout ceci est en grande partie le
reflet de mesures que vous avez
votées, peut-être pas tout le
monde.
Nous allons continuer à protéger
l'économie française, mais soyons
optimistes, soyons volontaristes,
arrêtons le défaitisme généralisé.
La France s'en sort mieux que tout
le monde.
Continuons.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Josiane Corneloup.
- Josiane Corneloup: Monsieur le
ministre de la Santé, la situation
financière des hôpitaux est
particulièrement préoccupante.
C'est le cas de tous les hôpitaux
publics.
L'ensemble des hôpitaux, peu
importe leur taille, doivent faire
face à des charges qui augmentent
plus vite que les recettes.
Le retour de l'inflation entraîne
un surcoût de 750 millions d'euros
annuels.
Les hôpitaux ne peuvent pas faire
face au surcoût des charges
générales qui s'envolent.
A cela s'ajoutent les hôpitaux de
proximité qui ne parviennent pas à
recruter des praticiens
permanents, le recours à des
praticiens intérimaires, ce qui
représente là-haut si un surcoût
élevé.
Quant à la hausse légitime du
point d'indice du personnel, elle
représente une dépense annuelle de
2 milliards d'euros qui n'a pas
été compensée par l'Etat.
Avec une dette de 3 milliards
d'euros,
trois fois plus qu'en 2002,
un nombre croissant
d'établissements doit emprunter.
Beaucoup d'hôpitaux sont aussi à
ce jour amenés à suspendre le
règlement des taxes sur salaire
pour payer les fournisseurs.
Si je salue la reprise de la dette
hospitalière par l'Etat pour 13
milliards et l'affectation de 6
milliards consacrés au plan de
relance, la situation des
hôpitaux, malgré une activité
inégalée.
Le personnel continue de faire
preuve du même dévouement observé
lors de la crise sanitaire, mais
travaille dans des conditions
difficiles, ils sont épuisés et au
bord de la rupture.
Cette situation ne peut plus
durer.
Notre système hospitalier a besoin
d'un vaste plan de refondation.
Il y a urgence vitale.
La personne qui vous a succédé à
la tête de SAMU France urgence
évalue à 150 le nombre de patients
morts aux urgences sur des
brancards sur le seul mois de
décembre 2022.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur François
Braun.
- François Braun: Madame la
députée, je vous rejoins lorsque
vous saluez l'engagement des
soignants qui tiennent encore
quotidiennement nos différents
services, qui sauvent tous les
jours, mais qui ne se retrouvent
plus dans notre système de santé.
Ils travaillent dans des
conditions trop difficiles.
Il y a besoin aussi de leur
redonner du sens.
Cette crise de l'hôpital que vous
signalez, c'est une crise de
l'ensemble du système de santé,
aussi bien en ville qu'à
l'hôpital.
C'est une crise qui dépasse le
cadre de la France et qui touche
tous les pays industrialisés
aujourd'hui.
Les solutions sont dans la
simplification, le retour à
l'humain, dans le bon sens, dans
les organisations comme dans les
financements de notre système de
santé.
30% du financement devrait être
redéployé différemment.
Je ne reviendrai pas sur ce
principe construit sur l'offre de
soins particulièrement délétère.
A l'hôpital comme en ville, il
faut plus de soignants auprès des
malades, il faut reconquérir nos
territoires en redonnant du temps
aux médecins.
Il faut les reconquérir aussi en
restructurant l'offre autour des
hôpitaux de proximité, mais chacun
à sa place.
Il faut organiser des coopérations
entre ces mêmes hôpitaux de
proximité, des hôpitaux de recours
et des hôpitaux supplémentaires et
il faut avoir une réponse adaptée
à chaque territoire.
Vous avez soulevé le problème de
l'intérim.
La limitation de l'intérim a été
votée par cette Assemblée l'année
dernière.
Je me suis engagé à prendre
l'arrêté qui réduit l'intérim
médical.
Nous aurons enfin un intérim qui
répond aux besoins et non plus un
intérim cannibale.
Il faut construire des réponses à
l'échelle des territoires.
Il faut restructurer le
financement des établissements.
C'est comme cela que nous
sortirons de la crise.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Nicolas
Pacquot.
- Nicolas Pacquot: Il fut un temps
où c'était un geste quotidien que
de coller un timbre sur une
enveloppe.
Ce 1er janvier, les Français ont
dit adieu au timbre rouge qui
rejoindra bientôt la disquette, le
chéquier ou la cabine téléphonique
au rang de ces objets qui ont été
le symbole d'une époque.
En lieu et place de la lettre
prioritaire, c'est un courrier
électronique qui sera adressé aux
postiers chargés de l'imprimer
avant de le distribuer.
Ce système rapide et efficace est
plus écologique à certains égards,
mais il pose des questions.
Nous savons que les services
publics de demain ne peuvent
ressembler éternellement à ceux
des années 60 et que, pour
s'adapter aux besoins actuels,
La Poste doit se réinventer.
J'ai pu lire que l'argent
économisé par le remplacement du
timbre rouge doit servir à
développer d'autres services de
proximité, à l'image des étapes
numériques.
J'ai assisté le mois dernier à
l'inauguration de la toute
première étape numérique au sein
du bureau de la poste de
Saint-Hippolyte.
Nous voyons que les citoyens qui
ont le plus recours au service
postal font partie de ces 23
millions de personnes encore en
difficulté avec le numérique.
Dès lors, comment garantir à
chaque citoyen un accès
satisfaisant au service postal?
Un guichet sera-t-il mis en place
au sein des bureaux de poste pour
les aider?
Comment garantir la distribution
des courriers?
Nos concitoyens s'inquiètent de la
future expérimentation, dans 68
villes de France, des tournées
allégées du facteur.
Cette nouvelle organisation
réveille une crainte fondée, celle
du recul des services publics.
Aussi, monsieur le ministre,
j'aimerais que vous puissiez nous
rassurer sur le fait que le
passage au tout numérique ne
remettra pas en cause la mission
principale du groupe La Poste,
celle de garantir un service de
proximité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Jean-Noël Barrot.
- Jean-Noël Barrot: Merci.
Monsieur le député, vous
interrogez le gouvernement sur les
évolutions de la politique de
courrier du groupe La Poste.
Il n'a pas échappé au gouvernement
que le passage du timbre rouge à
la lettre numérique suscite chez
les concitoyens un certain nombre
d'inquiétudes légitimes.
Permettez-moi de rappeler les deux
constats sur lesquels s'appuie
cette évolution.
D'une part, les usages de nos
concitoyens ont évolué.
En 2010, ils envoyaient 45 lettres
prioritaires par an.
Ils n'en envoient plus que 5 par
an en 2021.
Deuxième constat, les évolutions
prévues par le groupe La Poste
permettront d'économiser 60.000
tonnes de CO2 par an, et ce grâce
notamment à l'arrêt du transport
aérien et à un meilleur
remplissage des camions.
Permettez-moi de vous donner
quelques éléments qui seront, je
l'espère, de nature à vous
rassurer et à rassurer l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens.
Les timbres rouges qui ont été
achetés avant le 1er janvier de
cette année continuent évidemment
à être fonctionnels.
Deuxièmement, la présence du
facteur est bien maintenue 6 jours
sur 7 pour l'ensemble des
activités du groupe La Poste sur
l'ensemble du territoire.
Les agents de La Poste pourront
aussi accompagner les concitoyens
qui seraient empêchés d'y parvenir
et de réaliser leurs envois de
courriers prioritaires.
Aussi, La Poste conserve une offre
rapide d'envoi de courrier avec
une lettre spécifique qui arrive
après deux jours et la lettre
verte qui arrive après trois
jours.
Les conditions sont réunies pour
la qualité du service postal.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Martine
Etienne.
- Martine Etienne: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de la Santé.
"On est à bout, on n'en peut
plus", c'est ce que les soignants
répètent depuis plusieurs mois
dans toute la France.
Alors que nous subissons une
triple épidémie de bronchiolite,
de Covid et de grippe, partout en
France, les services d'urgence
sont contraints de fermer faute de
personnel.
Ceux qui restent ouverts sont
submergés et n'ont pas de moyens
supplémentaires.
Résultat: le syndicat SAMU
urgences de France fait état de
150 personnes qui ont trouvé la
mort de manière inattendue parce
qu'ils attendaient sans être
soignés, alors qu'ils étaient aux
urgences.
Cela fait des mois que les
soignants vous alertent, qu'ils
disent qu'ils sont au bord du
craquage.
Vous ne les écoutez pas.
Il
est dur pour eux de faire leur
possible au détriment de leur
propre santé.
Sans financement, sans recrutement
et sans moyens supplémentaires en
place, ils ne s'en sortiront pas.
Le 31 décembre dernier, lessivés
et épuisés par des cadences
intenables et des conditions de
travail inhumaines, 50 des 55
infirmiers et infirmières des
urgences de Thionville ont été
placés en arrêt maladie.
Le mouvement a été suivi par les
soignants de l'hôpital de Pontoise
qui sont nombreux à être en arrêt
maladie.
Cette situation est symptomatique
du sous-financement de l'hôpital
public et de la libéralisation du
système de soins en France.
Quand donc allez-vous écouter les
soignants?
Quand allez-vous endiguer la casse
de l'hôpital public?
Quand allez-vous constituer un
véritable service public de santé
en rouvrant les services des
urgences, en revalorisant les
salaires et en redonnant du sens
au travail des soignants?
Combien de morts encore avant que
vous ne réagissiez?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur François
Braun.
- François Braun: Merci.
Madame la députée, je ne
répondrais pas à votre dernière
remarque, vous le comprendrez, vu
le métier que j'ai exercé pendant
plus de 30 ans.
Je connais la situation des
services d'urgence.
Je connais bien les urgences de
Thionville.
Vous parliez de la triple
épidémie.
J'en profite pour rappeler
l'importance de l'application des
gestes barrières et de la
vaccination pour lever la pression
sur les services d'urgence.
Je ne doute pas que vous aurez à
coeur d'appliquer ces consignes
simples.
Mon premier mot sera pour soutenir
ces gens qui travaillent dans ces
services, mes anciens collègues,
qui arrivent à tenir à bout de
bras un système.
La situation décrite dans certains
services est inacceptable.
Je m'assure de la mobilisation des
directions d'établissements, avec
les ARS, pour trouver une solution
pour ces situations au plus vite.
Les urgences sont le réceptacle de
nombreux problèmes de notre
système de santé.
Il y a souvent un manque de
disponibilité de lits pour
hospitaliser les patients.
Face à ces difficultés, nous
agissons avec des réponses
immédiates.
Je ne vais pas revenir sur les
mesures qui ont souvent été
prononcées, sur la revalorisation
des heures de nuit, mais il y a
aussi la volonté de former mieux
et plus vite les soignants, mieux
organiser l'hôpital en sortant de
cette logique financière
concurrentielle entre
établissements, et nous voulons
aussi travailler avec les
territoires.
Nous connaissons la pénibilité du
travail de nuit.
C'est en agissant sur tous ces
leviers que nous leur permettront
de gagner ce défi.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Philippe
Naillet.
- Philippe Naillet: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
délégué chargé de l'Industrie.
Vous le savez, l'article 73 de la
loi égalité réelle en outre-mer,
votée en février 2017, a instauré
l'expérimentation durant cinq ans
de la stratégie du bon achat
ultramarin.
Dans le cas de la commande
publique locale, l'objectif est de
favoriser par l'achat public
l'émergence d'entreprises locales
et la création d'emplois avec une
première disposition qui a permis
aux acheteurs publics de récupérer
une économie locale.
Il y a aussi l'obligation de
présenter un plan de
sous-traitance prévoyant le
montant des modalités de
participation des PME locales.
Le dispositif s'éteindra à la fin
du mois de mars.
Vous savez également que dans le
territoire, la demande publique
influe sur l'activité économique.
Ces dispositifs de différenciation
sont des leviers primordiaux pour
le développement de notre tissu
économique, composé à 93% de très
petites entreprises et dont les
deux tiers n'ont pas de salariés
et ne répondent pas d'elles-mêmes
aux appels d'offre.
Cette stratégie est une des
réponses adaptées aux
problématiques économiques et
sociales de nos territoires en
permettant plus de concurrence
pour développer l'emploi local et
ainsi réduire la pauvreté qui
frappe de trop nombreuses
familles.
Bref, l'obligation de
sous-traitance des PME locales
permet l'accès à de plus gros
marchés.
Il est proposé dans un rapport de
reconduire ces dispositions.
Plusieurs recommandations ont été
émises pour faire évoluer et
rendre plus efficients ces
dispositifs.
Ma question est simple: comment
comptez-vous réaliser ces
dispositifs et les améliorer?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Roland Lescure.
- Roland Lescure: Merci de votre
question.
Vous avez raison, le marché public
représente 120 milliards d'euros
par an pour le territoire
national.
C'est un puissant levier pour
l'économie.
Sur ces 120 milliards, 60% était
des PME.
La loi a été votée en 2017.
Elle est pertinente, notamment
dans les départements que vous
représentez.
Les acheteurs auraient pu racheter
un tiers du marché public aux
entreprises locales.
Force est de constater que ce
dispositif a été loin d'avoir du
succès.
Seul 4% des acheteurs l'ont mis en
oeuvre, notamment à cause d'un
risque juridique lié à
l'imprécision du texte voté à
l'époque, et un manque de
clarification sur les secteurs
économiques concernés.
Nous ne voyons pas, à ce stade, un
intérêt réel à proroger ce
dispositif dans les mêmes
conditions au vu de sa faible
mobilisation sur le terrain.
Bruno Le Maire l'a évoqué
récemment, nous souhaitons porter
en 2023 un projet de loi de
réindustrialisation verte dans
lequel l'économie publique doit
avoir sa part.
Un certain nombre de
parlementaires sur les bancs de la
majorité vont s'appliquer à parler
de ce sujet.
Nous devons intégrer des
dispositions particulières dans ce
dispositif en assurant l'égalité
de tous et toutes sur le
territoire.
Dans le mandat précédent, nous
avons voté des dispositions qui
visent à intégrer davantage les
enjeux environnementaux et
sociétaux.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Marie Fiévet.
- Jean-Marie Fiévet: Ma question
s'adresse à madame la secrétaire
d'Etat chargée des Anciens
combattants et de la Mémoire.
Ce mercredi 4 janvier, le film
"Tirailleurs" est sorti au cinéma.
Cela raconte l'histoire d'un jeune
homme et de son père, enrôlés de
force dans la guerre.
Il y a des polémiques autour de la
mémoire de ces unités coloniales
recrutées dans les différents
territoires de l'empire français.
Ne les oublions pas.
L'histoire des tirailleurs est
souvent méconnue.
Créée en 1857, le statut de
tirailleurs sénégalais est donné
aux hommes recrutés dans toute
l'Afrique subsaharienne faisant
partie du corps militaire des
troupes coloniales.
A la création du premier régiment,
ils étaient environ 500.
Lors de la Grande guerre, c'est
plus de 200.000 tirailleurs
sénégalais qui se sont battus sous
les couleurs du drapeau français.
Ils étaient engagés dans les
combats pendant la Deuxième Guerre
mondiale également.
Ils étaient aussi en Indochine, à
Madagascar.
En réponse à cet engagement et
malgré les polémiques pouvant
ressurgir, l'Etat se doit
d'apporter et apporte une
reconnaissance juste à ces anciens
combattants.
Ainsi, au-delà de l'actualité
cinématographique, pouvez-vous
nous rappeler quelle était la
réalité historique de l'apport des
tirailleurs à l'armée française
durant de nombreuses décennies?
Combien sont-ils aujourd'hui?
Quelle est leur situation
géographique et sociale?
Pouvez-vous nous préciser comment
l'Etat et le gouvernement
accompagne ces anciens grands
combattants et leur apporte la
reconnaissance qui leur est due?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Patricia Mirallès.
- Patricia Mirallès: Les
tirailleurs sénégalais sont des
combattants issus des anciennes
colonies d'Afrique subsaharienne
qui se sont engagés au sein de
l'armée française pendant la
Première Guerre mondiale.
Près de 200.000 d'entre eux se
sont engagés pour défendre notre
drapeau.
Leur contribution pendant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale vaut à
deux d'entre eux de reposer dans
la crypte du Mont-Valérien.
Ils se sont battus vaillamment
avec honneur et fierté pour notre
pays.
Ils sont l'objet d'une attention
constante de mon secrétariat
d'Etat, sous l'autorité de
Sébastien Lecornu, ministre des
Armées.
Les marques de reconnaissance ne
manquent pas, mais la
reconnaissance est un travail
continu.
Depuis mon entrée au gouvernement,
j'ai travaillé pour pouvoir
dénombrer précisément aujourd'hui
ces hommes.
Une trentaine de tirailleurs
sénégalais octogénaires et
nonagénaires vivent dans des
foyers de travailleurs,
essentiellement à Bondy.
Avec le ministre des Solidarités
et le ministre de l'Agriculture,
nous avons relevé à titre
exceptionnel l'obligation de
résider en France pour la
perception du minimum vieillesse,
afin qu'ils puissent finir leurs
jours dans leur pays.
C'était une question d'humanité.
En décembre, après les avoir
rencontrés à Bondy, ils m'ont
accompagnée pour le rallumage de
la flamme sous l'Arc de triomphe.
C'était un grand moment.
La vérité du film avec Omar Sy est
de rappeler aux Français une page
de notre histoire qui est oubliée.
Je m'assure que la nation
considère ces grands anciens
combattants avec respect et
attention.
Vous pouvez compter sur moi,
monsieur le député, sur ma
détermination, pour continuer à
accompagner ces grands tirailleurs
sénégalais.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Jiovanny William: En ce qui
concerne le chlordécone,
arrêtez de nous dire
que 92 millions suffiront
à pallier vos responsabilités.
Cessez de couvrir vos erreurs par
des plans qui ne feront qu'attiser
la compréhension du peuple, déjà
en souffrance.
Il s'agit, pour vous, d'être au
rendez-vous de l'histoire.
Mesdames et messieurs les
ministres, quand allez-vous
prendre la mesure de vos
responsabilités.
La population est touchée dans sa
chaire et dans son âme par cet
empoisonnement et par cette
non-reconnaissance qui nous tue un
peu plus chaque jour.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Jean-François Carenco,
ministre en charge des outre-mer.
- Jean-François Carenco: Merci.
Je constate comme vous la décision
prise par les autorités
judiciaires en toute indépendance.
La pollution au
chlordécone est un sujet grave,
qui suscite de l'angoisse et de la
colère chez nos concitoyens
antillais.
En tant que ministre en charge de
l'outre-mer et l'ensemble du
gouvernement, notre priorité est
de protéger la santé, d'aider les
secteurs économiques impactés et
de renforcer les recherches pour
améliorer l'ensemble des terrains.
Nous devons continuer à avancer
dans le chemin ouvert.
En 2018, le président de la
République est le premier à avoir
reconnu la responsabilité de
l'Etat,
sous son impulsion des avancées
fortes ont déjà été obtenues:
reconnaissance du cancer de la
prostate comme maladie
professionnelle.
Il y a aussi l'analyse gratuite du
taux de chlordécone pour toute la
population.
Il y a l'accompagnement des
agriculteurs et des particuliers
pour cultiver des produits sains,
y compris sur les terres
contaminées.
Il y a un effort national de la
recherche qui a été engagé.
Ce sont quarante laboratoires de
recherche dans
l'Hexagone et les outre-mer qui
sont mobilisés.
Le colloque scientifique et la
rencontre sur le terrain du mois
de décembre ont été l'occasion de
porter à la connaissance, à notre
connaissance, les avancées.
On a aussi vu qu'il restait
beaucoup à faire.
Je vais me rendre en Martinique
dans les jours qui viennent.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Une réponse?
- Jiovanny William: Il n'y a pas
de paix sans justice ou sans
responsabilité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Philippe
Ballard.
- Philippe Ballard: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame
Agnès Pannier-Runacher.
Parlons du marché régulé de
l'énergie, ou l'art de créer un
problème là où il ne devrait pas y
en avoir.
Le gouvernement raconte des
mensonges aux Français.
Vous affirmez que nous voulons
sortir du marché européen de
l'énergie.
Mais qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire?
Couper les câbles et les réseaux?
Non.
Nous avons toujours réclamé le
juste prix, c'est-à-dire revenir
sur la règle européenne de
fixation du prix.
Nous voulons retrouver des tarifs
réglementés, mais les vrais, ceux
qui tenaient compte du coût réel
de la production.
Nous voulons éviter que notre
dette explose.
Cela éviterait à Emmanuel Macron
de déclarer qu'il en avait assez
"de ceux qui faisaient des profits
excessifs".
C'est bien de pleurer sur le lait
renversé, mais le mieux, c'est de
ne pas renverser la casserole.
Vous dites que vous faites tout
pour réformer ce mécanisme.
Ce n'est pas rapide.
Le patron du MEDEF a appelé
Emmanuel Macron à engager un bras
de fer avec l'Allemagne sur ce
sujet, craignant une nouvelle
vague de désindustrialisation de
la France, ce mécanisme européen
n'était pas réformé.
Mais pour engager un bras de fer,
il faut de la volonté et du
courage politique.
En juillet 2023, dans six mois, il
n'y aura plus de tarif réglementé
pour le gaz.
Que comptez-vous faire pour éviter
l'asphyxie des ménages et des
entreprises pour les prix du gaz,
et quand comptez-vous reprendre le
contrôle de la fixation du prix de
l'électricité?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Agnès
Pannier-Runacher.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs, monsieur le
député Philippe Ballard, merci de
me donner d'abord l'occasion de
rappeler la politique du
gouvernement, une politique du
gouvernement qui est la plus
protectrice d'Europe, pour les
ménages français, puisque vous
payez le prix de l'électricité le
plus bas d'Europe, pour les TPE,
puisqu'elles payent le prix le
plus bas d'Europe, et pour les
PME, puisqu'elles bénéficient
d'une protection à travers les
amortisseurs et les aides du
guichet de Bercy, une des plus
généreuses d'Europe.
Nous serons toujours aux côtés des
Français et des entreprises, comme
nous l'avons été ces dernières
années, au bénéfice de la
croissance, de l'emploi et de la
souveraineté de notre économie.
Vous m'interrogez sur la situation
du marché européen.
Je vais vous rappeler quelques
données.
Nous sommes dans une situation où
nous importons de l'électricité.
Nous savons produire plus
d'électricité sur le territoire
français aujourd'hui.
Votre groupe refuse de voter un
projet de loi qui doit nous
permettre de développer plus de
capacité de production
d'électricité.
Soyez cohérent et soutenez la
souveraineté énergétique de notre
pays.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Vous n'avez plus de temps, cher
collègue.
La parole est à madame Marie
Pochon.
- Marie Pochon: Merci.
2,3 millions de personnes
mobilisées, une condamnation
historique en 2021 qui exhortait
l'Etat français à prendre les
mesures utiles pour le climat
avant le 30 décembre 2022.
Cela vous rappelle peut-être
quelque chose.
C'était l'affaire du siècle.
Ce siècle débute encore et devrait
se terminer à + 4 degrés.
Faute d'une vision claire de notre
énergie, l'Europe est devenue le
plus grand importateur de gaz de
schiste américain.
Sécheresse, incendie, absence de
neige, ces choses auront eu au
moins quelque chose de positif.
Le président de la République a
semblé découvrir l'impact du
changement climatique.
Qui aurait pu prédire cela?
99% des scientifiques du monde.
Il faut agir avec toutes les
cartes en main.
L'effondrement de la biodiversité
et le réchauffement climatique
concernent notre capacité, dans
quelques dizaines d'années, à
vivre sur cette Terre.
Nous vivons dans le monde de
demain avec la société d'hier.
Deux condamnations pour inaction
climatiques.
Vous parlez des écoterroristes,
mais les criminels, ce sont ceux
qui regardent le monde s'enflammer
en gardant les bras croisés.
Comment osez-vous menacer ceux qui
vous demandent de respecter la
loi?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Agnès
Pannier-Runacher.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs, madame la
députée Marie Pochon,
vous évoquez la condamnation du
gouvernement français pour
inaction climatique entre 2015 et
2018...
Un gouvernement auquel votre
groupe politique a participé.
Vous m'interrogez sur ce que les
gouvernements du président Macron
ont fait pour rattraper le temps
perdu et corriger votre inaction
climatique.
Le rythme de réduction des gaz à
effet de serre a été multiplié par
deux par rapport à votre bilan.
Depuis 2018, la France a voté un
agenda ambitieux de réformes
écologiques:
accélération de la décarbonation
de l'industrie, et une économie de
5000 ans gaz à effet de serre par
an.
Je ne reviendrai pas sur l'action
décisive de la France pour faire
adopter le paquet climat au niveau
européen.
Vous pouvez encore être dans la
bonne catégorie en votant ce
projet de loi.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Nathalie
Serre.
- Nathalie Serre: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin.
Monsieur le ministre, mardi 3
janvier dernier, dans une commune
de ma circonscription de la
métropole lyonnaise, un homme a
été tué au pied d'un bâtiment
abritant un centre social, une
crèche et une école, à l'heure de
la sortie des écoles.
Sur fond de trafic de drogue, ce
drame n'est pas le premier ni le
dernier.
Dans tout l'Hexagone, ces
situations se multiplient, que ce
soit à Marseille, à Nantes, ou à
Lyon.
La politique de la ville menée
depuis 2014 laisse ces quartiers
être gangrenés par le trafic.
Désormais, les mesures ont pour
effet de sortir les quartiers
difficiles des radars.
On a simplement caché la poussière
sous le tapis.
Les services de secours, les
médecins et les forces de l'ordre
sont reçues à coups de pied ou de
jets de parpaing.
Le nombre de victimes par homicide
était en hausse en 2021, tout
comme le nombre de victimes de
coups et blessures volontaires.
Quand allez-vous prendre la mesure
de l'exaspération des Français?
Quand l'Etat va-t-il reconquérir
ces territoires?
Il faut donner aux forces de
l'ordre les moyens de combattre
les trafiquants.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Je partage nombre de ces constats,
notamment le fait que la loi de
2014 n'était pas une bonne loi.
La politique de la ville mise en
place par ce gouvernement a fait
sortir des quartiers des radars.
Ce sont des quartiers populaires
qui ont besoin de davantage de
République.
En revanche, vous comparez les
chiffres en ne citant que l'année
2021.
En 2022, vous auriez pu noter que
la délinquance a baissé, notamment
au deuxième semestre.
Ces trois derniers mois, il y a eu
une réduction de 15% des
violences.
Il y a eu une réduction de 30% des
points de deal.
Dans le Rhône, il y a -50 % de
violence dans les transports.
Nous devons continuer ce travail.
C'est en augmentant les effectifs
de la police de la gendarmerie que
nous allons y arriver.
Dans le Rhône, c'est trois fois
plus de policiers et de gendarmes
qui nous permettent d'obtenir ces
objectifs.
Les forces de l'ordre font un
travail important.
Nous continuons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Madame Nathalie Serre?
- Nathalie Serre: Merci pour votre
réponse.
Dans les transports, c'est
l'action de Laurent Wauquiez.
La violence se banalise.
Les habitants ont besoin de
sécurité.
Les maires ont besoin d'aides de
l'Etat.
C'est ce que l'on attend d'un Etat
de droit.
- Gérald Darmanin: Monsieur
Laurent Wauquiez n'a rien à voir
dans l'affaire.
Les policiers, c'est l'Etat
français qui les met dans les
transports.
Vous ne combattrez pas le Front
National en faisant un tableau
noir de la situation.
Vous permettrez aux policiers et
aux gendarmes de faire un travail
admirable en remarquant leurs bons
résultats.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Luc
Lamirault.
- Luc Lamirault: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de l'Economie.
Je défends depuis plusieurs mois,
avec le groupe Horizons, le
principe d'une résiliation à tout
moment et sans frais, des contrats
de fourniture de gaz,
d'électricité, pour les
entreprises et les collectivités
territoriales.
Beaucoup ont été contraintes de
souscrire à l'automne des contrats
sur la base de prix
exceptionnellement élevés, qui les
placent aujourd'hui dans une
situation intenable.
Avec le président, Bruno Le Maire
a annoncé des mesures fortes, qui
vont dans le bon sens.
Il y a d'abord la possibilité
donnée aux artisans boulangers de
résilier sans frais et à tout
moment leur contrat.
Il y a l'étendue du bouclier
tarifaire pour les TPE et PME.
S'il est certain que ces mesures
d'urgence sont bienvenues,
envisagez-vous un mécanisme plus
pérenne pour qu'à l'avenir, les
PME ne soient plus captives sur la
durée de prix anormalement
excessifs?
Quant aux collectivités
territoriales, le filet de
sécurité défendu par le groupe
Horizons permet un premier
soutien.
Mais elles restent contraintes de
fermer l'accès à des équipements
de service public essentiels et de
réduire leurs investissements.
Est-ce que vous envisagez
d'étendre aux collectivités la
portée des récentes annonces?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Roland
Lescure.
- Roland Lescure: Merci.
Monsieur le député Luc Lamirault,
merci pour votre question et vos
alertes.
On a eu l'occasion, tous les deux,
d'évoquer ce sujet récemment.
Pour cette partie des membres de
la majorité qui nous ont alertés
très tôt du fait que les
dispositifs annoncés devaient
faire l'objet d'un élargissement
et d'un renforcement pour les très
petites entreprises, les
boulangers, qui, du fait de la
hausse des prix de l'énergie, se
retrouvent en difficulté.
Vous l'avez dit, sous l'impulsion
du président, nous avons annoncé
des réponses fortes.
Aucune des TPE de France ne pourra
avoir un bouclier tarifaire qui va
plafonner son tarif moyen de
l'électricité.
Elles pourront le faire sans
passer par une renégociation des
contrats.
Les fournisseurs d'énergie seront
avant tout aux services de leurs
clients.
Cette révision des contrats va
permettre de baisser les factures
de manière forte et de retrouver
des prix beaucoup plus viables.
L'économie française résiste
extrêmement bien au choc
énergétique auquel l'ensemble de
l'Europe fait face.
C'est en partie grâce aux mesures
adoptées
par le gouvernement et à la
résilience de notre tissu
industriel et commercial, qui
résiste bien.
Pour l'instant, on a une économie
française qui résiste bien.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Frédéric
Mathieu.
- Frédéric Mathieu: Merci.
Madame la présidente, ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre.
Le 23 décembre, un homme déjà
condamné pour des violences
racistes a ouvert le feu au centre
culturel kurde de Paris, faisant
trois morts et plusieurs blessés.
J'en profite pour assurer les
familles de victimes de ma
solidarité.
Le 23 décembre, la thèse vite
propagée était celle d'un racisme
pathologique.
S'il convient de souligner que le
racisme n'est pas une maladie,
mais un délit qui a conduit à un
triple assassinat, la similitude
avec le triple assassinat du 9
janvier 2013 pose question.
Le jour et l'heure de l'attentat
correspondaient à un rendez-vous
qui devait réunir des
représentants kurdes.
En 2013, les personnes visées
étaient impliquées dans la
communauté kurde.
Nous savons que l'attentat de 2013
portait l'empreinte des services
secrets turcs.
Nous devons considérer la piste de
nouvelles ingérences de la
Turquie.
Entendez-vous travailler cette
hypothèse?
Entendez-vous réduire le
secret-défense au strict minimum
pour que les familles des victimes
ne soient pas confrontées à la
même absence de réponses que
pendant l'attentat de 2013?
Avez-vous déjà mis en place des
mesures pour garantir la sécurité
de l'ensemble des Kurdes de
France?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
Merci.
- Gérald Darmanin: Je veux
également apporter aux familles
des victimes et aux Kurdes, en
particulier, nos plus sincères
condoléances.
Le garde des Sceaux a reçu les
représentants de la communauté
kurde à plusieurs reprises.
Je veux aussi remercier les
personnes qui ont arrêté cette
personne, qui était rentrée dans
le salon de coiffure et qui a tiré
sur ces personnes-là.
Les forces de secours ont pu
limiter le bilan extrêmement
meurtrier de cette tuerie.
Nous avons pris, bien sûr, toutes
les mesures de protection de la
communauté kurde, de leurs lieux
culturels, mais aussi, après
discussion avec l'ensemble des
préfets, des manifestations qui
s'en sont suivies, pour exprimer
leur colère.
Je suis cependant surpris par vos
propos.
Ce n'est pas dans un Etat de
droit, au ministre de l'Intérieur,
au gouvernement français, que
d'étudier des pistes, mais c'est
aux magistrats.
Ils agissent indépendamment de
toute action politique.
Ce sont les magistrats qui se
saisissent et qui qualifient
eux-mêmes les faits de terroristes
ou non.
Ils creusent ou non telle ou telle
piste.
En posant cette question, soit
vous ignorez totalement l'Etat de
droit et vous pensez que le
ministère de l'Intérieur commande
les enquêtes judiciaires, soit
vous utilisez ce drame ignoble
pour faire croire que l'Etat
français a des choses à cacher.
Je vous demande, dans l'hémicycle,
de respecter les principes de
l'Etat de droit et de laisser les
magistrats faire leur travail.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Pascale
Bordes.
Excusez-moi, il reste 10 secondes.
- Frédéric Mathieu: Je suis
scandalisé par vos propos.
Personne n'est en train
d'instrumentaliser ce drame.
Le 12, j'organise un colloque,
ici, pour lever le secret-défense
et aboutir à la vérité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Pascale
Bordes.
- Pascale Bordes: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de la Santé.
Je me suis rendu il y a quelques
jours dans un hôpital de ma
circonscription, à
Bagnols-sur-Cèze, dans le Gard.
Les soignants font un travail
extraordinaire.
Les urgences de cet hôpital sont
saturées.
L'hôpital est en pénurie de
professionnels.
Cet hôpital souffre d'un manque
cruel de lits et les brancards
s'accumulent dans les couloirs,
laissant les patients côte à côte,
dans une promiscuité peu
compatible avec leur état.
J'ai croisé un patient âgé de 78
ans allongé sur un brancard, sans
aucune intimité depuis 36 heures,
faute d'un lit.
C'est de la maltraitance et de
l'inhumanité qui compromettent la
guérison des patients.
La situation est d'autant plus
critique que la population est
vieillissante.
Les personnes âgées sont de plus
en plus nombreuses à venir aux
urgences.
Nous ne devons plus accepter la
maltraitance des patients, la
surcharge des urgences étant
responsable d'une augmentation de
la mortalité.
Notre système de soins est à bout
de souffle.
Il faut prendre des
mesures pour rétablir des
conditions de soins descentes.
Avant qu'il ne soit trop tard.
Sinon, il y aura des décès de
personnes qui n'auront pas pu être
soignées à temps.
C'est votre responsabilité en tant
que ministre.
C'est la responsabilité du
gouvernement.
C'est la responsabilité des
parlementaires ici.
Comptez-vous prendre des mesures
pour mettre un terme à cette
maltraitance des patients et des
soignants?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur le ministre de la Santé
et de la Prévention?
- François Braun: Madame la
députée Pascale Bordes, je vous
remercie de votre diagnostic qui
est malheureusement connu.
Nous avons beaucoup d'actions à
faire.
Vous auriez pu reconnaître les
actions qui sont faites depuis six
mois.
Il y a eu l'appui des
professionnels de santé sur le
terrain.
Mon objectif est de prendre soin
des Français, mais aussi des
soignants.
Ils sont auprès de nos concitoyens
tous les jours.
Trois axes: simplifier,
collaborer, valoriser, dans le
cadre de ces missions de santé
publique auprès des soignants.
Plusieurs solutions ont été
dessinées par le président.
Il y a le fait de gagner du temps
de soin.
Il y a aussi le fait de travailler
de façon collective, à échelle
humaine, sur le territoire.
Nous avons pu identifier des
pistes spécifiques pour chaque
territoire.
Il y a l'organisation au sein de
l'hôpital ainsi que l'organisation
au plus près des individus.
Je souhaite passer un pacte avec
les élus des territoires pour
améliorer la qualité de vie des
soignants en ce qui concerne les
transports et les aides.
Troisième point: la permanence et
l'universalité des soins en
reconnaissant la pénibilité, en
faisant tomber les barrières entre
la ville et l'hôpital, entre les
hôpitaux et les cliniques, entre
les professionnels de santé.
C'est ce que nous avons fait
pendant le Covid.
Enfin, il faut reconnaître le rôle
du médecin traitant généraliste.
Il faut continuer le déploiement
du service d'accès aux soins.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Laurent
Panifous.
- Laurent Panifous: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de la Santé.
Cette année encore, la période des
fêtes a été marquée par de grandes
difficultés pour les soignants et
ce sur tout le territoire.
Début juin, le syndicat du SAMU a
alerté sur la situation dégradée.
Parmi les dysfonctionnements, il y
a les hôpitaux de mon département.
Les indicateurs en Ariège sont
parmi les plus mauvais.
Par exemple, il y a une
agglomération passée de 21
médecins à 6 médecins aujourd'hui.
A l'échelle du département,
l'effectif est en baisse.
Les médecins ont connu une hausse
de 20% de leur activité.
En cause: le vieillissement de la
population et la désertification
de la médecine de ville.
C'est la double peine pour la
population de l'Ariège.
Un accès fortement dégradé aux
soins de ville mais aussi aux
urgences, qui étaient le dernier
rempart face à ce qui ressemble
non plus à de la désertification
médicale, mais a de la misère
médicale.
L'égalité d'accès aux soins n'est
plus assurée aujourd'hui en Ariège
et dans beaucoup d'autres
territoires.
Ce sont parfois les soignants qui
doivent faire des sélections pour
guérir les patients.
Face à la tension du service des
urgences et au burn-out du système
hospitalier, l'heure n'est plus à
la réflexion.
Comment votre gouvernement peut
intervenir concrètement pour
garantir aux Ariégeois et aux
Français, confrontés aux mêmes
difficultés, l'accès aux services
d'urgence digne d'un pays
développé?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur François
Braun.
- François Braun: Monsieur le
député Laurent Panifous, je vous
remercie d'avoir souligné ce
principe de difficulté au cours de
cette fin d'année, avec les
absences de médecins, mais aussi
avec cette triple épidémie.
J'aurais tendance à revenir sur
les gestes barrières et la
vaccination, mais vous connaissez
le message.
La crise des services d'urgence
est liée à une difficulté au
niveau de la médecine de ville et
aux dysfonctionnements à
l'hôpital.
Elle est aussi liée à une
diminution de l'offre par rapport
à une augmentation des besoins.
Vous parliez d'indicateurs.
Je serais ravi de discuter avec
vous de cette problématique
ariégeoise que je connais bien.
Je voudrais revenir sur cette
notion de besoin de soins.
Il y a des densités différentes,
mais il y a surtout la question
des besoins et la façon dont nous
allons répondre à ces besoins.
Vous avez parlé de régulation
médicale.
C'est une des solutions.
Le président de la République a
annoncé que nous allons
généraliser l'ensemble des accès
aux services de soins en
renforçant les moyens humains.
Nous allons continuer ce qui a été
mis en place.
Nous allons valoriser les
professionnels de santé qui
acceptent de prendre en charge des
patients dans le cadre de soins
non-programmés.
Nous allons réorganiser l'hôpital,
notamment les services.
Nous le ferons au niveau du
territoire.
Nous sommes dans une logique
d'action.
Le diagnostic est connu.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Géraldine
Bannier.
- Géraldine Bannier: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre de
l'Education nationale et de la
Jeunesse.
Une étude du service statistique
de votre ministère indique
qu'environ 21% des élèves âgés de
15 ans n'ont pas un niveau
suffisant de compétences en
compréhension de l'écrit, culture
mathématique et culture
scientifique.
C'est un peu mieux que la moyenne
européenne.
Mais cela reste inquiétant.
Sur une même dictée de 67 mots,
sans complexité extrême à la
Pivot, proposée à quatre
générations depuis des années, le
nombre de fautes a augmenté.
27% des examinés ont commis plus
de 27 erreurs.
On nous demande au collège de ne
plus corriger l'ensemble d'une
copie de rédaction.
A cela s'ajoute une perte de
vocabulaire.
Un linguiste indiquait en 2015 que
10 % de la population française ne
maîtrisait
que 400 à 500 mots contre 5000 en
moyenne pour la majorité des
Français.
Pour les mathématiques, il y a le
même constat.
En Angleterre, Tony Blair avait
imposé la lecture quotidienne.
En France, on constate
que la collégienne que j'étais
dans les années 90, sous le
ministère de François Bayrou,
bénéficiait de plus d'heures de
français.
On a perdu 522 heures de français.
Pouvez-vous revenir sur les
mesures annoncées par rapport à ce
difficile constat?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Pap Ndiaye.
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci.
Madame la députée, je partage ce
constat.
Mais il faut regarder la vérité en
face, à propos des savoirs
fondamentaux.
Ces dernières années, un travail
important a été mené pour les
premières années de l'école
primaire, du côté du cycle 2, en
particulier des travaux qui ont
donné des résultats intéressants,
notamment en éducation
prioritaire.
Nous devons mettre l'accent sur le
cycle 3, c'est-à-dire le cours
moyen et la sixième.
Un rapport a récemment mis le
doigt sur un certain nombre de
difficultés dans les
apprentissages en français et en
mathématiques.
Je ne prendrais qu'un exemple: la
question de la rédaction, de
l'écriture, qui n'occupe que 7% du
temps en CM2.
Nous devons mettre l'accent sur la
formalisation des apprentissages,
la diversité et la régularité des
productions écrites, et en
mathématiques, la résolution des
problèmes de calcul mental.
En sixième, c'est une année
charnière.
C'est le lieu de la grande
divergence, le moment où les
trajectoires des élèves divergent
entre les élèves qui poursuivent
une trajectoire normale et ceux
qui vont plonger.
Nous devons mettre l'accent en
sixième sur un travail extrêmement
précis, sur les fragilités que
nous identifions grâce aux
évaluations de sixième, de manière
à travailler soit sur
l'orthographe, soit sur la
grammaire, soit sur les
opérations, et nous devons
travailler sur ces fragilités.
D'autres mesures viendront en
cinquième, en quatrième et en
troisième, pour faire du collège
un lieu qui ne soit plus le lieu
de l'échec.
Nos collégiens doivent pouvoir
poursuivre du côté du lycée
général ou technologique ou du
lycée professionnel.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La séance des questions au
gouvernement est terminée.
Nous reprendrons à 17h15 pour le
vote sur le projet de loi relatif
à l'accélération de la production
d'énergie renouvelable.